hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his discussion of anger and rhetoric
book two aristotle is going to identify
and briefly discuss
a number of situations and people
that are liable to lead to greater anger
and what is the greater here so the
greek term is malone and we could think
about this in terms of just the
intensity of the anger but we also might
think about it in terms of how long
it lasts or what kind of
retribution or satisfaction the person
is going to demand and there aren't
absolute rules about this these are sort
of generalizations
that aristotle himself is noting and i
should point out that the context of the
rhetoric is learning about the emotions
not for their own sake but so that you
can
appeal to them
as a rhetorician as somebody who's going
to use these emotions to try to
get an audience to to do something or to
not do something to say something to not
say something to feel in a certain way
and view things a certain way so this is
not an absolutely comprehensive
list aristotle is not writing a
psychology textbook about anger he's
just noting some of the things that we
can learn from experience that may be
helpful for us to
have top of mind so there are things
that can provoke anger to a
greater extent and a lot of these have
to do
with the kind of person or the kind of
actions
that they're engaging in or failing to
engage in so the first that he talks
about
and here he explicitly says
people get angrier right he invokes the
malone at the beginning of this passage
with those of little account right or of
little account and made any logo using
people who are considered to be
not as important they don't have higher
social status
they may be viewed as in certain
respects beneath us and why should this
make us angrier he tells us that when
these people
slide us
anger at a slight was assumed to be felt
at those who ought not to
behave in such a manner tus may pro
pros econ
and this goes to the definition of anger
where aristotle said the sliding itself
if it's going to make us angry has to be
unjust undue you know inappropriate
it shouldn't be
what happens and so you know if somebody
is serving us a drink and they're like
you know
hope you swallow it down you fat slob
you know maybe that would be an example
of what we're talking about here as a
server they're perceived as being
inferior to the customers and they
shouldn't be behaving in such a way now
if they were at a restaurant where
that's the norm it wouldn't be perceived
as wrong right it'd be like oh yeah yeah
you know i am a slob let me down this
right away but you know in a typical
situation that's that's the way
it works and so
people who are inferior according to you
know are sort of social mores should not
be giving a hard time to people who are
at least equal or superior to them in
some respects so we'll get angrier
when they have the effrontry to do such
a thing right or well i can't believe
that they talked to me that way it would
be you know angering if somebody who's
on my same level talk to me that way i
can't believe that this person you know
the scum of the earth or just you know
an inferior person would would say these
sorts of things or would you know do
these sorts of things so that's one
dynamic another very interesting one
that he knows has to do with friends
and he says that well we get angry with
friends
when
they fail to do some things when they
don't speak well
legusian right or treat us well
a poison they don't behave
well towards us now
why because there's an expectation that
friends should be friendly
to each other should do good things and
speak well of each other and then
aristotle says we get
even more angry when the friends do
the
opposite and what is the the opposite
the anantia in this case well it would
be
um not just not speaking all of us it
would be speaking badly of us when our
friends
run us down behind our backs or even in
front of us you know think about
frenemies who are always rivaling with
us about things and say little little
sarcastic comments right uh give us
compliments that aren't really
compliments or
treating us well the opposite would be
treating us poorly treating us not just
as
not just friends
but as as enemies to some degree or as
people of no account well we get angrier
with our friends why
again as with the first one because
there's a social expectation there
and we could also say a very basic human
psychological
expectation that those who were close to
should be
treating us well should give preference
to us so that's an important one
with the others aristotle doesn't come
out directly and use the term to a
greater extent in greek malone but i
think that we can read that into the
context
of these passages and so one group of
people that we we do get angry with and
can get angrier with are those who
rejoice or are
cheerful
now the greek terms for this
uh are going to be
uh here we go epihyrussi
so hydra you know hiring is to rejoice
rejoicing about something in particular
and then the the cheerfulness
right it's coming from this word
thumbos
which is by the way is is sometimes used
synonymously with anger but sometimes
designates this larger
scope of orexis or desire within
aristotle that includes anger but also
includes other things so those who are
in good spirits you could say
now
we don't get angry at people just for
rejoicing or being in good spirits
when do we get angry at them for that
when
we are experiencing what in greek is
called atukia
misfortune
things going badly for us a
failure a
lack of success you know so for example
aristotle doesn't provide us with any
but
for example when we
lose a job or
when a relationship breaks up or
when
our child is injured or
when our paper gets sent out or a book
set gets sent out and the publisher is
like this is garbage right seeing other
people rejoicing or at least in a
generally good mood makes us feel bad
and that feeling bad can translate into
anger and even into greater anger why
aren't you bothered by the fact that
these bad things are happening to me why
are you
having a good time
it sort of speaks of a
lack of care and consideration so we can
we can get angry with those
another he talks about when um
here we go
uh
those who don't care if they cause us
pain
and you know this is a perception matter
right so what would be some examples
of these um
those who bring us bad news they don't
care
that they're actually causing us pain
now a lot of times people bringing us
bad news are actually quite upset about
the fact that they have to tell us
something bad they'll say you know
please uh sit down you know is there
anything i can do for you
that might not anger but somebody coming
along a prime example of this in uh
academic life when you apply for jobs
and there's you know anywhere from
200 to 1000 applicants for an academic
position
much more in the median of like 300 to
500 and you get that
email
long after you've applied for the job
and it says oh we had many qualified
candidates we regret to inform you you
will not be moving on to the next uh
segment sequence whatever it is the next
steps for this
people can get quite angry about that i
can't believe they turned me down right
uh that's bringing bad news also we get
angry at those who as aristotle says
listen to accounts akuane in greek who
like to hear bad stuff about us kaka
right
or who
witness who
see
us
uh doing bad
theomen noise right
and so um
you know this fala is is the the bad
things
um this could be like bad things
happening to us this could be
bad things that we have done or
that we
said or anything like that it's kept
very generic
we can get angry with those who are
doing that and sometimes we can get
angrier
again notice the common element here
because there's some sort of
perceived norms
being violated right they shouldn't be
listening to those things about us they
should be defending us right
another one that's very interesting now
aristotle says that anger can arise not
only at
sliding directed at us as individuals
but also
those
things or people that we
are concerned with or are connected with
or identify with or
you know in some way feel like
it falls into our
purview so you know somebody who
is very interested in darts if you make
fun of darts maybe they get angry at you
right
those that we're really concerned with
are people who are
connected with us and are vulnerable and
aristotle actually goes a little bit
further
and says those who it would be
shameful or
dishonorable
for us not to defend and the greek word
for defending there is very interesting
it's actually
the word that's used for come to aid
like rush to aid as
an allies as they're angry with those
who slight such persons it would be
disgraceful that's another good
translation of icecrown not to defend
and who does he give as examples there
there he actually does
give examples gones parents
techna children
gunaikas
a wife
or wives
dependents
literally those who are being
ruled or determined by one so the
members of one's household
if you happen to have a managerial
position in a company your reports your
employees the people that you're
responsible for aristotle says that
we
are you know we have a responsibility
and we are also perceiving ourselves to
have a responsibility
to look out for to defend these people
against the slights that could be done
to them by other people and we're more
likely if we're you know at least decent
people to get angry about that
than we are if somebody makes fun of our
love for stamps or checkers or
songbirds or something like that
another one that's very very interesting
those who do not show gratitude is how
it's typically translated
the greek is a little bit more complex
twice hiring me apo didducin so people
who we've done some sort of benefit to
and they are not responding
to us abu didducine literally means like
give there's the word giving in there
and a little bit earlier aristotle
actually talks about
those who do not return
kindnesses
antipoyun
um with the primitive may in front of it
so the the idea is if you're benefiting
a person first if they can they should
try to benefit you in return
if they can't provide similar benefits
they should at least provide some other
things honor affection attention
those sorts of matters and so that is
how you actually show
gratitude a sense of
the other person having done something
for you
and aristotle says that we get angry
with those who don't show gratitude and
we might get angrier
the
more that they show contempt by you know
forgetting us or things like that
aristotle by the way
also tells us in this section although
i'm not sure that we can say that it's a
greater you know being angrier he tells
us that forgetfulness lathay is actually
a cause
of anger and it can be understood as a
sort of
contempt cataphronesis one of the three
main modalities of sliding so forgetting
a person's name forgetting that you've
you know
committed to doing something for them
that can make us angry he doesn't
actually say that that can make us angry
yours so that's why i didn't put that
here and then one other that i think is
really quite interesting and we can
relate to in our own time
particularly those employing
irony right those who are being ironic
is another way of translating it and
it's coming from the greek toys
errol new menus right literally it's
coming from
irony those who use irony those who
don't just
self-deprecate oh who am i to say
anything about wisdom i have no wisdom
you may recognize socrates there
but those who also use irony with
respect to other people
especially with things about which those
people are
serious or take seriously the greek
there
is um
spudadzontas right and uh this does mean
to take seriously to to value is another
way of thinking about it so you know you
play a
record of the band that you love that's
just got a new album out for somebody
and they're like oh yeah i guess that's
kind of cool if you're into
you know
old hair metal
you know that that must be really
awesome to go to listen to them with all
the other aged fans and hear them play
the same you know three chords over and
over again okay
and then i'm just being ironic and
you're like damn it i don't like that
when you talk that way about my band
right or anything else um
coming along and the famous meme of the
guy opening the door well well the kid
is playing some sort of game and they're
like are you winning are you winning can
sometimes be a ironic statement right so
that can make people angrier as well
particularly as the irony gets heaped on
and heaped on and heaped on
you know once you start being ironic
about something that somebody else is
serious about
it's kind of hard to dig yourself out of
that hole without apologizing right if
you just say i was being ironic they
said well why were you why didn't you
care about this thing that i take
seriously so all of these are factors
that can lead to an intensification
of anger on the part of the person who
is in fact feeling that emotion
perhaps the anger is provoked directly
by these things or perhaps it's a
mixture where they're already angry and
they get angrier because these sorts of
things happen
and in some cases it's going to lead to
a greater intensity just by itself
you